[Music]  i have a hard time with people so here  we go  social media has like changed the way we  think like the way we process our own  language like how we sound i remember in  the 16 election they were talking about  the rock  maybe running for president i said that  to a friend i was like yo i heard the  rock my run for president my buddy was  like is the rock a democrat i was like  dude listen to the sentence  that you just said is the rock a  democrat i don't know he's a fake  wrestling character  i don't know where he stands on health  care  is the rock a democrat i don't know do  the yellow power rangers support the war  in iraq what the [ __ ] are we talking  about  where does mickey mouse stand on  abortion i don't know  is he a second trimester or before kind  of mouse or more like a hard line life  begins a conception folks  [Music]  you